how's your spread making skills i still
spread to this day g.o.d my daughters
don't [ __ ] with it but [ __ ] i still
spread to this day what's like what's in
your see mine like i'm a gourmet spread
[ __ ] i ain't no real jailhouse [ __ ] to
the point where i could bust down the
sweet and sour or you know i'm saying
chicken chow mein and you know [ __ ]
fries shrimp fried rice like [ __ ]
[ __ ] know how to wet burritos tamales
[ __ ] know how to really bust that [ __ ]
down in there i'm just a uh i'm a butt
naked type [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying so you know you just you get the
you boil the noodles boom i mean throw
the cheese in there hot the hot sauce
you crush up all the chips spread that
on top of that
put a couple jalaenos in there ah grab
you a little tortilla
throw that over there real quick you got
your little spring there yeah that [ __ ]
sounds like diarrhea nice candy lick you
not hearing me i do this every day
you're still eating that every day every
like whenever i'm seeing me my
significant she pump faking she acting
like she ain't she don't want to make
dinner you're like don't worry i got
this i got i can handle this myself she
pump faking on lunch oh no problem yeah
i'm saying so yeah we got to get you an
air fryer mozzie
i got one i don't know how to utilize it
so you put anything in it and just hit
start and it's it's anything you could
put a raw chicken breast in that [ __ ]
you know i told you [ __ ] i'm i'm bougie
nowadays so what's they call that you
but you're eating spread every day not
that bushy ain't that bougie but what's
that [ __ ] they call uh uh uh uh
not grubhub oh postmates postmates oh
you just post me
how much i'm probably one of eight yeah
i'm saying i'm one of their clients all
kinds of bossa nova coming in huh bossa
nova cheesecake factory
um they'd be taxing too they do be
taxing but it's smooth though cause it's
like you ain't gotta go you ain't gotta
go but there's the risk that it comes
and it's [ __ ] cold or it's all [ __ ]
up and i have somebody nah but it's cool
because it's coming to your house so say
if you order a rib eye and that
[ __ ]
and you want that [ __ ]
extra yeah you just re-rock it it's my
feet
now imagine if you see imagine if you
order it and you're on the road and then
you know i'm saying you pick that
[ __ ] up and then you all jump on
the freeway and then you're not gonna
drive back home
yeah you can't do nothing with it [ __ ]
just can't eat it you know what i'm
saying but whatever that when they come
when they land at the house on the front
porch i don't even open the door for
them i let them drop it off drop brushes
i don't even want to see you yeah